here's another person and he uh gave it
a shot as well but again did not address
the static
questions that i'm asking he went into
the into dynamic mode immediately and he
says
light is just a vibration in the ether
medium okay so he he didn't
tell you what the ether is what this
medium is that he's talking about
but he's saying it's it's a vibration
and
you know there's my picture of it my
interpretation of what he's saying
here you have this ether vibrating out
there in uh
in the universe whatever uh the black
stuff supposedly a space
that gives contrast to this ether right
and then in one location somewhere in
the universe or
in many locations obviously we have a
vibration of these particles and that's
going to be
light okay that's essentially what he's
saying light is just a vibration
in the ether medium okay and um
so what we first need to do is uh compel
this to stand still we want to stop
any motion because we want to identify
the object and so that's
what we do we we stop the motion and
there it is
now we can breathe easy now we can see
what we're talking about okay and
what we see is again bunch of particles
that's all the ether is
uh so what does he say to this well
he uh he in other words what are we
staring at what what is this
uh this ether stuff and he says well
this is what they are he says the
medium is dipolar electrons and
positron pairs particles that repel each
other
okay he said a mouthful there because uh
here we have the electron
positron okay he says that forms the
ether but he
still has not told me what the black
stuff is that's what i want to know i
want to know what the black stuff
i want to know what contours each one of
these two particles
and then he's got a second issue there
that you know he says oh they uh they
repel each other
okay so how do they do it i mean do they
do it the plus sign just hits the
negative sign
is that how they bump away i mean why
would they repel each other
why do all these particles repel each
other you know
what is the physical reason that's what
i want to know okay
or why would they attract that uh
assuming they do also attract but
here we have a positive and negative
they repel each other and we don't know
why they repel each other because
at least in mathematics positive
attracts negative i mean they would
repel each other both of them were
positive or both of them negative but
here we have
uh you know an electron which is known
to be negative positron which is
supposedly a positive electron you can
think of it that way
and uh positive attracts negative and
they should
you know in fact they should they they
do uh theorize that these two things
come together and annihilate each other
so why they they repel each other we
have no idea
and but the most important part is that
we still don't know what the black stuff
is and that black stuff is is is what
i'm trying to get to with my questions
okay
so it's important that we're trying to
get the to the bottom of the black stuff
uh the thing that contours the last
particle in the universe
you can't just keep saying well a
particle is countered by particles which
is contoured by more particles you can't
do that
at some point the bug has to stop